a sleeping anger has been awoken
in english football now it's the turn of
manchester united fans
the corps of supporters have opposed to
the american glazer family since they
took over this club
16 years ago but this is no small
minority
here they are in their thousands the
ill-fated european super league has
started a fire
and it's ripping through the game the
glazers
they're not they're not about the club
they're about money they're about greed
they're about turning us into a cash cow
and that's what we don't
we don't want to be that they don't
allow the closing room for the last uh
10 years
uh taking a billion pound out of the
club by the club in debt leveraging
against club
uh treating people like their
commodities
calling fans legacy fans when setting up
the super league um
just gone too long enough's enough every
time i go to a gun i pay 40 quid i don't
want to give five quid
to an american owner who really doesn't
care
these protests had been well publicized
but the scale and ferocity surprised
police and security at old trafford
there are fans who have made their way
into the ground
and they are now protesting they've come
through the bottom end the stratfor then
is away to my left
they're now heading out onto the pitch
to let their feelings be known
this is obviously not what we want to
see and the security here at old
trafford
has failed hundreds of fans breaching a
cordon around the ground
just hours before manchester united were
due to play liverpool
in a pivotal premier league fixture one
being greeted by perhaps the most
influential united fan of them all
i think all football fans should unite
today behind what manchester united
fans have done because honestly what
they did two weeks ago was really
dangerous for english football we must
not forget that
they tried to walk away and create a
close shot league
that would have basically created a
famine a famine
in this country for every other football
club
supporters also gathered at the city's
lowry hotel
inside players from both teams unable to
leave
the game was finally called off more
than an hour after the original kick-off
time
and this is the man many fans hold
responsible
for a perceived erosion of the club's
values and rising debt
joel glaser the co-chairman of
manchester united
was a driving force behind the european
super league
it was undertaken without consultation
of supporters
fueled by greed with no regard for the
history of the game
themes these fans believe have
characterized the glazer family's reign
but others believe the protests are both
misguided
and pointless i think it's born out of
man united not being top dogs as much as
what happened last week
i think that's another excuse to have a
go at them these are serious serious
business people
i don't this will this will impact on
their thoughts
one iota the premier league expressed
sympathy with police and stewards who
dealt with the protests
in a statement they said we understand
and respect the strength of feeling
but condemn all acts of violence
criminal damage and trespass
especially given the associated kovid 19
breaches
fans have many channels by which to make
their views known
but the actions of a minority seen today
have no justification
the date of the rearranged fixture has
yet to be decided
but events of the past fortnight may
have marked the beginning
of football's great revolt and
revolution
martha kellner sky news